THE US MILITARY ANNOUNCING AN
AMERICAN SAILOR, MARKING THE
FIRST INFECTION TO THE US
MILITARY IN EUROPE.
CHARLES: DONALD TRUMP SIGNING
THE BIPARTISAN A.3
BILLION-DOLLAR CORONAVIRUS AID
BILL.
ONLY TWO MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
VOTED AGAINST IT, MY NEXT GUEST
IS ONE OF THEM, ARIZONA
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN ANDY
BIGGS.
FIRST QUESTION, WHAT THE HECK
WERE YOU THINKING ABOUT?
>> WHAT I AM THINKING ABOUT IS
THIS HAS BEEN HYPERBOLA AND THE
POLITICIZATION THAT HAS GONE
ON, THE ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE
A GOOD JOB, $2.5 BILLION BEFORE
AND AFTER THE VOTE.
THAT IS WHAT I SAID I WOULD
VOTE FOR.
THAT -- CHUCK SCHUMER
POLITICIZED THIS AND THEY
BACKED INTO THE 8
BILLION-DOLLAR MONEY AMOUNT AND
1 BILLION OF THAT OVERSEAS.
THEY NEEDED $2.5 BILLION.
IF THEY COME BACK 3 MONTHS
LATER, WHATEVER, WE CAN DO IT.
JUST BECAUSE IT IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO DOESN’T MEAN YOU
TRIPLE THE MONEY THAT IS PUT TO
THIS EFFECT.
THERE’S A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION, THIS REMAINS A
LOW RISK LOW CHANCE -- PEOPLE
GET IT FOR THE VAST MAJORITY.
DAVID: 415-NUMTWO, SOMETIMES
THERE IS A POLITICAL L ON
SOMETHING AS FRIGHTENING AS
THIS.
I’M WITH YOU 1000%, THE
COVERAGE HAS BEEN DELIBERATELY
TO CREATE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
PANIC IN THE STOCK MARKET AND
MAIN STREET BUT BY THE SAME
TOKEN YOU MENTIONED COMING BACK
TO CONGRESS, THE KIND OF
LEADERSHIP PEOPLE DON’T WANT TO
SEE, MAYBE BEING OVER PREPARED,
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT
TO SEE.
LAST THING YOU WANT IS TO THIS
TO EVOLVE TO A PLACE WHERE THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC SAYS WE ARE
CAUGHT FLAT-FOOTED AND HAVE TO
GO BACK TO CONGRESS TO LET THEM
MUDDLE THROUGH THE NEXT ROUND
OF FUNDING.
>> I HAVE TO PUSH BACK ON THAT
A LITTLE BIT.
THE ADMINISTRATION SAID THEY
NEED $2.5 BILLION, ADDITIONAL
FUNDS FROM OTHER SOURCES AND
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS YOU
PUT A TRIGGER IN HERE SAYING
ONCE YOU SPEND $1 BILLION WE
TRIGGER ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
THIS IS NOT BEEN DONE BECAUSE
IT IS TO PREPARE US, SENDING
THIS MONEY FOR YOUR 5 YEARS
OUT, DEALING WITH NEGLIGENT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND MOVING
FORWARD WITH A PLAN.
THIS IS RESPONDING, REACTING IN
MY OPINION RECKLESSLY BECAUSE
OF THE SPENDING.
YOU COULD HAVE DONE THIS IN AN
ORDERLY WAY.
THEY CHOSE TO POLITICIZE IT AND
THAT IS WHY YOU GET $8 BILLION
WHEN YOU SHOULD HAVE DONE 2.5.
DAVID: I UNDERSTAND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES, YOU NEED TO
SPEND AN EXTRA THINGS AND IT
HAS SPIRALED OUT OF CONTROL AND
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE THOUGHT
YOU FOR STICKING TO YOUR
POLITICAL CONVICTIONS.
IT WAS A DANGEROUS GAMBIT IN
SOME WAYS BUT AND MARK MEADOWS
AND CHIEF OF STAFF HOW YOU FEEL
ABOUT THAT.
>> MAKE HAS DONE A GREAT JOB, I
WILL MISS HIM IN CONGRESS.
HE IS A GREAT FRIEND, TO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND DONALD TRUMP.
STEVE: 0 DONALD TRUMP SENDING
TROOPS TO THE BORDER AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO THING AND
BEFORE THEN A RUSH TO GET IN
BEFORE THE SUPREME COURT.
IS THIS THE RIGHT MOVE?
>> IT IS THE RIGHT MOVE IN THE
MPP PROGRAM HAS WORKED AND I